two years ago today House Minority Whip
Steve Scalise suffered a
life-threatening wound when a gunman
opened fire during a practice for the
Congressional baseball game Louisiana
congressman was hit in the left hip by a
rifle bullet he spent 20 days in
intensive care and nearly six weeks in
the hospital his book back in the game
one gunman countless heroes and the
fight for my life tells the story of the
shooting it's now available in paperback
uns congressman Scalise is here with us
first on CTM congressman good morning
welcome thanks for being here good
morning good to be with you it's great
to see you let me start with remarks
from the president we did we just
reported on that the president said he'd
listen to dirt on a political opponent
offered by a foreign government is that
acceptable from as in in your view is
that acceptable from a president or from
any candidate for that matter well it
was a hypothetical in the end if
something like that was actually
presented to his desk you know I'm sure
things would be different and I've seen
him respond both to hypotheticals and
then act differently as he's presented
actual facts and so when you talk about
this I know he used Norway as an example
but in the end you know it was a
hypothetical what would you know in that
sort of world what would you do in that
circumstance congressman I think clearly
you know when when you talk about
interference of foreign governments
we've been fighting against that for a
long time and you've seen even this
administration the Trump
administration's been very aggressive at
punishing Russia for what they did try
to do to interfere with our elections
and I think that needs to be pointed out
because president Trump's taken very
aggressive actions against Russia for
what they did as well as taking steps to
make sure it doesn't happen in the 2020
election because it did happen in the
2016 election with Barack Obama right
answer would be called the FBI well
calling the FBI calling authorities
would be absolutely something I would do
well you know but in the end if you look
at this that's why I don't when you're
posed with hypothetical questions you
know let's talk about real-world
examples and again the president's been
very aggressive against Russia in the
things that they actually did in 2016 I
just want to talk briefly about the
China the trade war with China and and
its impact on Louisiana because we spoke
with our affiliate WFAA be that spoken
is some of the farmers down in your home
state about this they're saying is
having a devastating impact what do you
say to your constituents there well what
I say is first of all all of our allies
around the world have been wanting us to
stand up to China because everybody
knows what China does to cheat on rules
to steal our intellectual property it
surely hurts Louisiana companies that I
talked to when they try to do business
with China and China's stealing a lot of
their intellectual property like they
steal so many things from contra
companies all over this country and so
having an aggressive negotiation with
China if it yields an agreement where
you can actually enforce those rules of
the game it would be a big win for
Louisiana for the entire United States
economy and for our friends around the
world
we've been reporting all this morning on
the the attack on two tankers in the
Middle East congressman and Iran's role
there are you concerned that we're
inching closer to war with Iran at this
point well you know without speculating
on where this goes we need to know what
Iran's been doing for a long time and
again the fact that we've been stepping
up aggressive actions to stand up to
what Iran is doing both to to try to
develop nuclear weapons which I surely
don't want to see them have a lot of our
allies don't want to see them have but
also what is this escalation here
indicate to you I mean David Martin said
the u.s. is calling this compelling
evidence well it shows you what Iran is
capable of doing we know that they help
terrorist organizations like Hamas and
Hezbollah they they're almost proxies
for each other they are proxies but in
the end the fact that we've been
standing up to Iran that a lot of our
allies want us to stand up to Iran
Israel our best ally in that whole
region and one of our best in the world
is very concerned about Iran getting a
nuclear weapon and this just shows you
why you don't want a nuclear-armed Iran
your book is in part about healing
political divisions so I just want to
get you on the record on one major
division in politics that's about
climate change
Louisiana according to researchers
falling into the Gulf of Mexico at about
a football field per hour so do you
accept the science of manmade climate
change and if so where's the plan to
address it well first of all the reason
that Louisiana loses a football field of
land every your own every single hour
scientists say it's it's an ask the
question Louisiana does lose
I'll field of land every hour because of
coastal erosion which is an appointed or
rise that is dealt primarily Gandalf the
Mississippi River sediment used to come
down from the top rate this for our
buildup we've the scientists have agreed
that the climate change is a
catastrophic risk do you have a plan as
some other members of your party are
beginning to to address I've got a plan
first of all we do know that the earth's
temperature changes it goes up and down
you don't accept a sign in the 1970s
they said we were entering a new cooling
period that's not what the scientists
are saying today so are you so let me
tell you what we're doing let me tell
you what we're doing in Louisiana we're
actually taking revenues from drilling
in the Gulf of Mexico and using that to
rebuild land to rebuild our coasts what
was lost from Cardinal off the
Mississippi River and it's I think a
real important step to show how people
can actually take ownership of the
problem that they have in their own
community if your constituents from
climate change you're drilling more in
the Gulf of Mexico well drilling the
money from drilling is actually being
used to help rebuild land ok it's really
you should go see it I'll invite you out
there I've seen it actually let's talk
about the book and it's your comeback
and what you learned from this process I
you talk about forgiveness
how are you forgiving and the man who
shot you yeah you know the the books
about really the the heroes and the
miracles that that all were at place
that day two years ago on that baseball
field the the heroes that saved my life
and everybody on the ball field day at
David Bailey and crystal Greiner the two
capital police officers so many other
police officers that were there that day
people like Brad Wenstrup heroes that
saved our lives but also the miracles
that that really kept people from from
making it through that day in terms of
forgiveness Michelle this has been
something I've struggled with as a
Catholic because I do want to get to a
point where I can truly forgive the
shooter I've talked to a lot of people
in fact it was in Opelousas Louisiana
one of the churches that was burned down
just a few weeks ago historically black
church that was targeted and burned down
one of three that was and I met with the
the pastor one of those churches the
Mount Pleasant Baptist Church and
Reverend Tucson he talked to me about
forgiveness and he said the first thing
he did when he found out who the
arsonist was at burned his church down
was that he forgave him
and it was powerful to me and I talked
to him about it we're gonna talk some
more how I'd hope to get there
congressman Solis it's a beautiful book
it's a beautiful message I will see you
on the Louisiana coast if you'll have me
I would love to have you down there and
you'll eat some great food but you'll
see how we're using drilling revenues to
rebuild real land out there in these
marshes I want to see it thank you very
much